attention ça y est Gainsbourg est tombé
dans la fosse
[Musique]
deux comédiennes assistent à
l'enterrement d'une troisième enlevée
prématurément à leur affection
mon Dieu quelle grande artiste nous
perdons dans la force de leur
du retour d'âge même
et si bonne camarade toujours gay avait
un petit verre dans le nez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça y est Gainsbourg est tombé dans la
fosse
bourré comme un cartable
pauvre et Edwige qui pouvait pas le
sentir et oui
la pauvre chérie quand je pense qu'après
1910 de suicide elle est morte bêtement
comme tout le monde un accident de
voiture avec 4 g d'alcool dans le sang
ça ne pardonne pas et puis elle venait
juste de se faire faire
ici le septième non oui
qu'elle pouvait même plus fumer une
cigarette
pauvre Edwige venue du trottoir
ça va encore durer longtemps j'ai
rendez-vous avec bicho de François bah
il est là justement tu as qu'à faire
d'une pierre de cou écoute tu plaisantes
je vais pas faire la promotion de mon
film il y a de l'ambiance devant le
cercueil quand même elle est belle dis
bonjour à Lino
sinon on va se taper la cloche après
avec Mireille il y en a une Miou pour
une fois qu'on a une occasion de se
rencontrer tu viens aussi en souvenir de
la pauvre Edwige qui aimait tant
s'empiffrer
je pense qu'elle est morte comme ça
c'est ta faute
ah bonjour Philippe il va me consacrer
sa chronique demain
elle ne devait pas faire le prochain
sauter
si t'excite pas
perdu de temps que veux-tu
faut bien que le spectacle continue
[Applaudissements]
Gaston tricard le Gaston triker celui
qui celui-là
entre nous soit dit un pas grand-chose à
moins que rien
enfin paix à son âme
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous êtes venus moi au
paramitié vous savez par amitié oh je
vous reconnais bien là
et vous oh bah moi ça me fait une petite
sortie
et vous savez toujours rester entre 4
murs et oui pour finir entre quatre
planches
[Musique]
et puis l'odeur des fleurs oh oui toutes
ces fleurs
il avait dans des amis cet homme-là ben
moi je la connaissais pas
on ne sait pas tout oh non
il paraît qu'il était presque beau sur
la fin
comme quoi ça vous change
il en a quand même fait baser à la
Simone
remarquez moi je l'aimais bien le Gaston
c'était pas le mauvais gars c'était pas
le mauvais gars c'était pas le mauvais
gars c'était pas le bon gars non plus
ça d'un autre côté
enfin Dieu est son âme
maintenant il se repose vous me direz
qu'il avait jamais beaucoup travaillé
ça une feignasse une vraie feignasse
il en a quand même fait 10 Go sur la
Simone il était toujours dessus hein
enfin lave la tranquille on peut dire
qu'elle fera pas tout doux toujours la
tournée des bistrots elle recherché ah
parce qu'il
paraît même qui buvait tout l'argent des
allocations
même qui devait de l'argent à tous les
voisins on peut dire qu'ils pourront
faire une croix dessus
[Applaudissements]
quel rhume je tiens moi
qu'est-ce que tu as foutu et voilà une
heure je tourne ok alors je ne trouvais
pas l'Église c'est leur a été frimeur
jusqu'au bout parce que pour se faire
enterrer sous son cours de tennis faut
le faire
c'est un mauvais goût surtout avec son
terrain
t'as pas pu assister à l'Alpe du corps
dommage on sera pas si c'était enterré
en short
[Rires]
[Musique]
en tout cas elle a fini par le est-ce
que tu crois qu'elle l'a tu penses on
fait pas faire de l'aérobic Annabelle
sketch à la goutte
maintenant qu'elle a touché le pack va
pouvoir ouvrir un club pour voir qu'elle
a eu du cœur à l'ouvrage parce qu'il
fallait se le faire le père
et on se relève
parler du bon Samaritain pour un type
qui a licencié les trois cartes sont
personnel tu parles il a acheté le curé
comme le reste dis donc tu trouves plus
ressemble
l'enterrer ou quoi on en est déjà au
condoléances
dis donc ça te dit rien de faire une
petite partie de tennis après
on y va
[Musique]